alors apparemment c'est ça on était en
train d'avancer sur met en oeuvre
côte à côte et j'ai frappé sur la porte
passager avec nos points
donc ben c'est pas il a peut-être
j'ai peut-être abîmé sa voiture ou et il
m'a projeté sur un camion il m'a blessé
quoi et du coup s'il a été accusé de
agression avec une arme
c'est passé ça a été un traumatisme
crânien et puis il m'a fait j'ai eu des
cicatrices et une fracture à la tête en
fait sur faciale et après j'ai été mis
en coma artificiel pour soulager la
douleur en fait à l'hôpital et ensuite
de ça ben ça a été
la réadaptation
même su rester à l'hôpital pendant deux
mois je crois et puis il a fallu que je
réapprenne à parler je réapprenne des
choses de base que je prenne ma vie en
fait presque pas c'était juste a le
cerveau cas qui a eu la douleur
je suis fait
finalement c'est pas si plus comment ça
s'appelle j'ai perdu mes mots mais c'est
l'endurance voilà j'ai beaucoup moins
dans dix ans auparavant alors qu'avant
on va aller comme le jour où j'ai eu mon
accident je vais faire ma journée en
tant que pour ses et je pouvais tenir
une somme une journée afin de rouler sur
mon vélo et tout est maintenant j'aurais
beaucoup de mal
récemment j'ai fait le tour de l'île et
bah ouais j'ai tenu deux heures
peut-être mais cette offre
au niveau santé voient ça comme va
continuer à ce que je fais depuis voilà
un an et demi quasiment à réapprendre ce
qu'il faut faire pour voilà être
indépendant entre guillemets
même si je suis pas totalement
indépendant mais c'est ce qu'il faut
donc j'aimerais bien faire peut-être des
études pour un travail ou entre amis
je sais pas on verra